Speaker 1: But I'll tell you, as I said, the
polls are shift and shift and in pretty good ways.
Right. And one of the biggest things that we're
seeing happening is that people are flocking away
from Donald Trump as a result of this January six,
you know, the televised hearings and everything.
And one of the people. Who is watching this
happening and seeing how Republicans are reacting.
Happens to be Republican pollster Frank Luntz.
Now, Frank Luntz appeared on CNN yesterday.
And on CNN, he was actually asked about
an issue I talked about yesterday,
Ron DeSantis beating Donald Trump in that new New
Hampshire poll. And here is what Mr. Luntz had to
say about that. When asked if DeSantis is a threat
to Trump. He said, quote, It's more than a threat.
The governor is proving that his approach
and what he's trying to accomplish and
what he has accomplished in Florida is more
significant. And Republicans are now saying
it's time to move on. There's now polling out that
shows that Donald Trump is actually paying a price
for what these hearings are showing. Now saying
that the Republican Party is ready to move on from
Donald Trump. Based on one poll from University of
New Hampshire with just a few hundred people and
I don't know that I'm willing to say
that, hey, Donald Trump's out of the
party. Everybody's moving on. That's reading
way too much into a single, way too early poll.
However, he's not wrong about the other
polls. Here's one of my favorite things.
Prior to that very first televised hearing,
two thirds of people in this country
did not believe that Donald Trump bore
responsibility for what happened on January six.
Today, two thirds of people in this
country believe that Donald Trump
bears responsibility for what happened on
January 6th. It literally flipped. It flipped
in two weeks, folks. Two weeks? That's pretty
impressive, right? And that's the point.
That's how powerful these hearings
are. That's why all of this matters.
Not just because we want to change
public opinion mostly, obviously,
because we want justice. We want those
people who broke the law to pay the price.
But I think we're all kidding ourselves if
we don't admit to at least a small degree
that there is some level of vengeance in us
that feels good about this, that wants it
to tank his approval rating, which it has. His
approval rating. Donald Trump's has gone down
since these committee hearings began. That is,
of course, what Frank Luntz is referring to.
People are tying Donald Trump directly to this.
And as I said, you've got Republican candidates.
Dr. Oz is a great one. They're running away from
him, even though Trump came out and backed and
made him. You know, had it not been for Trump,
Oz probably wouldn't have won that primary.
Same thing with J.D. Vance. I don't know if J.D.
Vance is running away from the Trump messaging,
but other people are more and more candidates.
And it's not because Donald Trump is still not an
influential figure in the party he is, and he will
remain an influential figure in the party whether
they want him to or not. He's there to stay.
He's your monster. You get to keep him forever.
But the voters out there.
They're not so happy with it.
And we're going to start to see, I promise you,
in the coming weeks, we're going to see more
and more Republicans start to run away from
him because, like Luntz said. It's having a
real impact on Donald Trump. It may not be
affecting the rest of the Republican Party,
these hearings at least, but if they
continue to try to tie themselves to Trump.
It will come back to hurt them in the midterms.
We need to take another quick break. I'm Theron
Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in for David
Pakman. And we'll be right back with more.